hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today's
question comes from Steve who's from my
forms and he was asking about getting a
subscriber list so we wrote in saying I
have a base of customers from an SEO
business but only around 120 subscribed
names is there a way of getting a larger
list of targeted people without buying a
list that's been hit so many times
they're cold leads thanks Steve so Steve
great question I'm not a huge fan of
targeting a list that have been blocked
usually again you know they have been
hit so many times that they're cold
leads and and they're not really
qualified people so you spend a lot of
time creating your messaging and the
content and you know getting a list and
you're talking to people who are not
know really constructive scuffling
customers for your business so I do a
little bit more work at the beginning to
find the targeted people that way all
the work that you do on the back end
with your content and your promotion is
going after people who are potential
customers for you which is at the end of
the day what you want for your business
I think the best way to be able to grow
that business grow that lead know that
list the number is to be able to partner
up with people so I look for people who
are already targeting your audience so
not a direct competitor but people who
have complementary services and see if
there's a way you can partner together
and it could be a number of different
ways it could be them you know make an
offer to their subscriber base and then
getting some kind of cut out of it it
could be them doing a review of your
product or service it could be you
writing a guest post for their website
it could be you guys creating a joint
product together and going to market
together to both of your lists find
creative ways now start talking to
people who again we're targeting the
same audience that you are but sell
complementary services and not
competitive services talking about what
you're doing in your business see if
there's a way you might be able to
partner up together and you know if you
do that with enough people if they have
a good list each of them then you're
able to target each of those lists
individually and be able to build your
name so that's that's one of the best
ways ideally they already have some kind
of relationship so for example people on
my list they're used to getting emails
from me on a weekly basis with content
and videos and helpful information
helping grow the business so I don't
really do promotional offers but if I
talk about something then the people who
are on my list are no loyal followers
are used to getting content for me so
they're likely to take whatever action
you know I recommend them doing if they
trust in like my advice so you want to
find partners who have a loyal following
and have a list of people who are used
to hearing from that person and they
trust what that person is saying so that
when they say hey this is great part you
gotta try out or here's a review of
something that I checked out and I
really like then they're going to pay
attention and they're going to hopefully
take action so it's better to have a
smaller list of highly targeted people
who are really loyal to that person and
are likely to take action then some
massive list of people who are not
engaged don't take any action air and
are really cold leads and are not
targeted to the type of people that you
want to target so hopefully that helps i
hope that can kind of you thinking
towards finding the right partners for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
and i was really happy seeing the thumbs
ups come in to appreciate that and if
you have a thought if you want to add to
this video or if you have a question for
me I always read the comments below so
please leave a comment underneath and
we'll see you on the next episode
you